This very moment of time and space is occupied
by everything that exists.
You, me, and everything in between.
We are all experiencing this same moment,
and we are all experiencing this same moment
differently.
Even if you and I were to look out the exact
same window at the exact same street at the
exact same time, it is likely that we would
both see and experience something different.
Perhaps you might enjoy watching all the people
walk by and musingly ponder about where they
could all be coming from and where they could
all be going.
And perhaps, I might look at all the traffic
and become tense with anticipation of the
chaos that I will be faced with when going
outside to commute somewhere.
Or perhaps you see the latter and I see the
former.
Regardless, it is likely that we both have
two different mental experiences of the same
thing at the same time.
But how is this possible?
How can we live on the same planet, sharing
the same reality, looking at the same objects,
yet all have different experiences?
We all have uniquely coded DNA.
And we all have unique pasts with unique upbringings,
influences, and environmental conditions.
All of these factors, and perhaps some others,
work together to form the lens out of which
we see the world and experience the life that
engulfs us.
And it is this lens that we form our self-identity
out of.
How we view and feel about things is all we
know.
It is our truth, and for our truth and identity
to be challenged is to feel the existential
sting of a thousand bees.
And as a result, everyone has something to
say about everything.
And everyone likes to think that they are
right.
But yet, we are often all saying different
and conflicting things.
And so perhaps sometimes, just because we
know we are right, does not always mean that
we are.
Amidst the world, there are countless ideologies,
philosophies, and perspectives that simultaneously
exist in direct conflict with each another.
There is Catholicism and atheism, monism and
dualism, nihilism and existentialism, and
endless more, all very different yet equally
as real and true to those who behold them.
The spectrum of ideologies in life is unending
and overwhelming.
What is the right one?
How do we know?
Can we know?
And if not, should we even subscribe to anything
at all?
In general, an ideology is simply a system
of beliefs and theories on how to live or
function.
But that is it.
And problems arise when we let our identity
and ego become so deeply engrained in a particular
ideology that we neglect to remember that
that is all it is.
That it is not a rigid and universal fact
of life.
It is just ideas, theories, and principles
constructed in an attempt to combat the inexorable
uncertainty and complexity of human life.
Truthfully, we are all in conflict with understanding
the life around us.
And when forming our beliefs and perspectives,
our goal should not be to subscribe permanently
and exclusively to something that sets limitations
for our self or others regarding what we can
experience, believe, and consider.
There is no universally correct ideology.
Perhaps there are some that consistently hit
closer to the sweet spot of common sense,
but there is currently no one-size-fits-all.
There are too many variances in the nature
and nurture of individuals for everyone to
agree on one ideology, and life is to complex
for one ideology to apply to every facet of
life.
If life is complex and constantly in flux,
so should we be, along with our beliefs and
perspectives.
True intelligence comes with the admission
of ignorance and the admission of our incomplete
pursuit of knowledge and understanding.
Intelligence is to engage in discussion with
other opinions, ideas, and perspectives and
consider them for what they are with openness
and reason.
If we want truth, we must be willing to pull
from varying ideologies, however dogmatically
contradictory they may be.
We must be able to consider individual concepts
and issues for what they are, using a combination
of scientific understanding, empirical evidence,
self-knowledge, personal reflection, and reason.
And we must do so, not seeking to see if they
fit within our existing beliefs and ideologies,
but to simply find the most accurate and applicable
answers to our questions.
To move fluidly with life and not get left
behind in our stalls of expired self-righteousness.